we have seen that several properties
such as for example linearity of
expectations are common for discrete and
continuous random variables for this
reason it would be nice to have a way of
talking about the distributions of all
kinds of random variables without having
to keep making a distinction between the
different types discrete or continuous
this leads us to describe the
distribution of a random variable in a
new way in terms of a so called
cumulative distribution function or CDF
for short and CDF is defined as follows
the CDF is a function of a single
argument which we denote by little X in
this case and it gives us the
probability that the random variable
takes a value less than or equal to this
particular little X we will always use
uppercase F to indicate CDF's
and we will always have some subscripts
that indicate which random variable
we're talking about the beauty of the
CDF is that it just involves the
probability a concept that is well
defined no matter what kind of random
variable we are dealing with so in
particular if X is a continuous random
variable the probability that X is less
than or equal to a certain number this
is just the integral of the PDF over
that range from minus infinity up to
that number as a more concrete example
let us consider a uniform random
variable that ranges between a and B and
let us try to plot the corresponding CDF
the CDF is a function of little X and
the form that it takes depends on what
kind of X we're talking about if little
X falls somewhere here to the left of a
and we ask for the probability that a
random variable takes values in this
interval then this probability will be 0
because all of the probability of this
uniform is between a and B therefore the
CDF is going to be 0 for values of x
less than or equal to a how about the
case where X lies some
between a and B in that case the
probability that our random variable
falls to the left of here this is
whatever mass there is under the PDF
when we consider the integral up to this
particular point so we're looking at the
area under the PDF up to this particular
point X this area is of the form the
base of the rectangle which is X minus a
times the height of the rectangle which
is 1 over B minus a this is a linear
function in X that takes the value of 0
when X is equal to a grows linearly and
when X reaches a value of B it becomes
equal to 1 how about the case where X
lies to the right of B we are talking
about the probability that a random
variable takes values less than or equal
to this particular X but this includes
the entire probability mass of this
uniform we have unit mass on this
particular interval so the probability
of falling to the left of here is equal
to 1 and this is the shape of the CDF
for the case of a uniform random
variable it starts at 0 eventually it
rises and eventually it reaches the
value of 1 and stays constant coming
back to the general case CDF's are very
useful because once we know the cdf of a
random variable we have enough
information to calculate anything we
might want to calculate for example
consider the following calculation let
us look at the range of numbers from
minus infinity to 3 and then up to 4 if
we want to calculate the probability
that X is less than or equal to 4 we can
break it down as the probability that X
is less than or equal to 3 this is one
term plus
the probability that X falls between 3 &
4 which would be this event here so this
equality is true because of the
additivity property of probabilities
this event is broken down into two
possible events either X is less than or
equal to 3 or X is bigger than 3 but
less than or equal to 4
but now we recognize that if we know the
CDF of the random variable then we know
this quantity we also know this quantity
and this allows us to calculate this
quantity so we can calculate the
probability of a more general interval
so in general the CDF contains all
available probabilistic information
about a random variable it is just a
different way of describing a
probability distribution from the CDF we
can recover any quantity we might wish
to know and for continuous random
variables the CDF actually has enough
information for us to be able to recover
the PDF how can we do that let's look at
this relation here and let's take
derivatives of both sides on the Left we
obtain the derivative of the CDF and
let's evaluate it at a particular point
X what we get on the right by basic
calculus results the derivative of an
integral with respect to the upper limit
of the integration is just the integrand
itself so it is the density itself so
this is a very useful formula which
tells us that once we have the CDF we
can calculate the PDF and conversely if
we have the PDF we can find the CDF by
integrating of course this formula can
only be correct at those places where
the CDF has a derivative for example at
this corner here the derivative of the
CDF is not well-defined we would get a
different value if we're differentiate
from the left different value when we
differentiate from the right so we
cannot apply this formula but at those
places where
the CDF is differentiable at those
places we can find the corresponding
value of the PDF for instance in this
diagram at this point the CDF is
differentiable the derivative is equal
to the slope which is this quantity and
this quantity happens to be exactly the
same as the value of the PDF so indeed
here we see that the PDF can be found by
taking the derivative of the CDF now as
we discussed earlier CDF's are relevant
to all types of random variables so in
particular they are also relevant to
discrete random variables for a discrete
random variable the CDF is of course
defined the same way except that we
calculate this probability by adding the
probabilities of all possible values of
the random variable that are less than
the particular little X that we are
considering so we have a summation
instead of an integral let us look at an
example this is an example of a discrete
random variable described by a PMF and
let us try to calculate the
corresponding CDF the probability of
falling to the left of this number for
example is equal to 0 and all the way up
to 1 there is 0 probability of getting a
value for the random variable less than
that but now if we let X to be equal to
1 then we are talking about the
probability that the random variable
takes a value less than or equal to 1
and because this includes the value of 1
this probability will be equal to 1/4
this means that once we reach this point
the value of the CDF becomes 1/4 at this
point the CDF makes a jump at 1 the
value of the CDF is equal to 1/4 just
before 1 the value of the CDF was equal
to 0 now what's the probability of
falling to the left of let's say 2 this
probability is a
one fourth there's no change in the
probability as we keep moving inside
this interval so the CDF stays constant
until at some point we reach the value
of three and at that point the
probability that the random variable
takes a value less than or equal to
three is going to be the probability of
a three plus the probability of a 1
which becomes three over four for any
other X in this interval the probability
that the random variable takes a value
less than this number will stay at 1/4
plus one half so the CDF stays constant
and at this point the probability of
being less than or equal to four this
probability becomes one and so the CDF
jumps once more to a value of 1 again at
the places where the CDF makes a jump
which one of the two is the correct
value the correct value is this one and
this is because the CDF is defined by
using a less than or equal sign in the
probability involved here so in the case
of discrete random variables the CDF
takes the form of a staircase function
it starts at 0 it ends up at 1 it has a
jump at those points where the PMF
assigns a positive mass and the size of
the jump is exactly equal to the
corresponding value of the PMF similarly
the size of the PMF here is 1/4 and so
the size of the corresponding jump at
the CDF will also be equal to 1/4 CDF's
have some general properties and we have
seen a hint of those properties in what
we have done so far so the CDF is by
definition the probability of obtaining
value less than or equal to a certain
number little X it's the probability of
this interval if I were to take a larger
interval and go up to some larger number
Y this would be the probability of a
bigger interval so that probability
could only be bigger and this translates
into the fact that the CDF is an non
decreasing function if Y is larger than
or equal to X as in this picture then
the value of the CDF evaluated at that
point Y is going to be larger than or
equal to the CDF evaluated at that point
little X other properties that the CDF
has is that as X goes to infinity we're
talking about the probability
essentially of the entire real line and
so the CDF will converge to one on the
other hand if X tends to minus infinity
so we're talking about the probability
of an interval to the left of a point
that's all the way out further and
further out that probability has to
diminish and eventually converge to zero
so in general CDF's
asymptotically start at zero they can
never go down they can only go up and in
the limit as X goes to infinity the CDF
has to approach one actually in the
examples that we saw earlier it reaches
the value of one after a certain finite
point but in general for general random
variables it might only reach the value
of one asymptotically